former 12-time All-American swimmer
Riley Gaines giving powerful testimony
on Capitol Hill on her fight to protect
women's sports Gaines telling Congress
what it was like to compete against
transgender athlete Leah Thomas
the number of female athletes who have
been denied opportunities traumatized or
hurt by policies that claim to promote
inclusion is growing at an alarming rate
defending women's rights does not
anti-anyone believing in biology is not
bigoted and following the science that
there are only two Sexes and that there
are very real and important differences
between the two Sexes is not hateful
it's fact there was even a group of
girls who
undressed in the Janitor's Closet they
change clothes in the janitors closet
because they felt more comfortable on
dressing in that environment than they
did undressing next to someone with male
gaze they were doing it because they
were violated Riley also standing up to
a Democrat who said that Republicans
were promoting hateful rhetoric listen
today transgender youth are among the
most at risk of homelessness depression
and death by Suicide
so when these young people who were
already struggling here politicians
amplify hateful rhetoric that denies
their very existence what message does
it send my combat to that is what
message does this send to women to young
girls who are denied of these
opportunities so easily their rights to
privacy and safety thrown out of the
window to protect a small population
protect one group as long as they're
happy
before we get to trans I hate to do this
to Jessica but I have to fact check her
because we don't accept misinformation
on the show California has the highest
homeless rate in the nation rate Florida
has the 21st highest rate in the nation
that check closed uh well it's not
please talk about the trans women look
no this is more important come on this
issue okay well I can't allow this
information judge would you like to say
something it's not true yeah yeah I do
want to say something I am so tired of
this whole issue they say that 1.4
percent of Americans identify as
transgender that means they identify as
transgender that doesn't mean that they
have trans or gendered okay I want to
know if Dick Durbin is so worried about
that 1.4 percent who identify as
transgender and may change their mind at
some point what about the 22 veterans a
day or 20 now who commit suicide every
day you want to talk about depression
you want to talk about PTSD let's talk
about the veterans who are killing
themselves because we sent them to war
and they did us a solid and we do
for them excuse me we do nothing for
them when they come back I'm sorry I
apologize now it's 2023 why do women
have to object to a guy watching them
undress what's with this bathroom
nonsense when did this start this is
what happened in Loudoun County Virginia
where girl gets raped by a guy in a
girl's bathroom the guy says he
identifies as a female the school sends
him to another school he then sexually
assaults another girl girls should not
be subjected to this we are defeating
women we are erasing women we're
minimizing them we're trivializing them
we're degrading them and yes we're
oppressing them so Dick Durbin come go
back to where it came from and you know
what I have a feeling where you came
from doesn't believe in what you're
talking about because they're not there
though that right they're not there
they're not standing there when a trophy
has to be handed over to a biological
male over a female competing in an
all-girls race I mean that's what
happened to Riley Gaines and what a
warrior she is she's not tiring by the
way I think she's getting stronger and
stronger in her message and by the way
she's not even she's not even saying
she's for an all-out band of
transgenders she's making it very clear
she was she's advocating for everyone to
compete where it's fair and it's safe
those are her exact words in this
testimony but she's fighting for biology
and why is that being ignored you go
back to that to that NCAA race against
Leah Thomas when it came down to I think
it was a hundredth of a second that
split the difference between them they
only had one trophy I'm sure you've
heard the story by now they handed it to
Leah Thomas yep she did not get a trophy
and when she asked the NCAA why she said
they were not prepared to answer that
question I believe she said that this
was just this is uh it came down to
picture purposes is what they said
picture purposes I mean think about that
happening to Collegiate young women what
are we doing and why is nobody in
greater numbers not standing up for
these girls who are trying to fight for
what they see and believe is the right
thing to do Greg Gutfeld well I am thank
you great I know you are it's I
sometimes I think like evil presents
itself as absurdity and in this case you
have a young successful woman being
attacked by an older man on behalf of
other men who claim that they are women
while keeping their genitals intact and
then when you dare as a as a woman a
successful female athlete ask to debate
they say that you're the bad person
because you are creating harm and and
and a threat to trans kids probably the
most cowardly defense and cowardly Point
ever to hide behind children you can't
even count or name you're talking to the
tiniest tiny percentage it's not it's
not even 1.4 it's like you're being
you're being chivalrous or or generous
actually
um so that is and if liberals want to
defend so so he what he does is he
shifted the debate to children
she didn't he did so all of a sudden now
you're into this world of gender
affirmation care which is the healthy
the removal of healthy organs from
children who are going through some kind
of confusion all right so if you the
Democrats Dick Durbin you want to defend
the removal of healthy organs for kids
have at it you'll just start another War
like you did with slavery and you're
going to lose this one too because no
one thinks this is good no one thinks
this is moral you have to ask yourself
when people were defending slavery and
when they were defending Jim Crow or
when they were going through Nazi
Germany why didn't people realize what
they were doing was evil there are
doctors that are removing healthy organs
they're they're removing external
genitalia breasts they're they're
blocking puberty which billions of
people have gone through billions of
people have gone through puberty the
idea of stopping it maybe perhaps it's
for a rare cancer but this is not what
we're talking about
these people don't see themselves as
villains they don't but they are and
they may not see this for years from now
we were talking about this about at 100
years we see eating animals as seeing as
something that is disgusting I don't
think you even have to go that far in 10
years the people that participated in
this Butchery they will lose their
medical license they may go to jail
because the more people learn about this
the more disgusted they are and it
crosses all political lines it crosses
all Races Creeds and get this sexual
orientation and some of these surgeries
don't even work very well you've heard
very traumatic stories about people that
have gotten the surgeries and let's just
not get into the detail but they didn't
work
absolutely
um and I think that for anyone who did
transition and now regrets it I feel
absolutely horrible for them that isn't
the vast majority of people who have had
gender affirming care and we're
conflating two issues as Greg said the
sports issue is very separate from
what's going on with the transit oh I he
brought it up I'm immediately pointing
out the conflation no right so I said as
Greg said like that was a nice thing
that I did you know like crazy like you
were saying I was conflating it no I'm
sorry okay great apology accepted so
seventy percent of Americans do not
think that
for example Leah Thomas should have been
able to compete on the Collegiate level
with girls that's a huge majority when
people win huge legislative battles on
less than 70 percent uniformity on an
issue like that and I think it's
important that Liberals are the ones who
are talking about this like me on TV and
others make that clear that this is one
of those issues where the activist class
is completely out of step with the
average person on these issues it is
also true that a majority of Americans
believe that states should not be
criminalizing gender affirming care and
that there are states that are going too
far and they're making it out to seem as
if you can just show up and get anything
you want done to yourself that you don't
need your parental permission you don't
need to go through psychiatric
evaluations or as if transgenderism
isn't a real thing that exists that it's
just confusion it isn't just confusion
people genuinely believe that they've
been born in the wrong bodies and they
lead happy lives once they have
transition questions should biological
males compete against
biological girls it to me it seems quite
clear that they shouldn't be able to and
I don't know what the solution is to
make sure that everybody can compete if
they want whether that means their own
lane that's open category some people
advocate for that um Bill Maher had a
guest on a she was a swimmer an Olympian
who has an organization for this
um or that's advocating for it I don't
know what the solution is but I know
that people shouldn't be losing their
scholarships necessarily for someone who
has a biological advantage and I think
one of the examples that was given in
the testimony yesterday was about uh
Serena and Venus Williams losing to the
203rd ranked and I think the women's
soccer team also lost to a younger men's
soccer team
um so I I think that we can make sure
that transgender people are protected
and also talk about the value of
competitive Sports and that it puts
people at a disadvantage I I'm also the
idea of elevating the targeted harm of
transgendered kids I need to see the
data on that because there are a lot of
miserable kids out there right now
thanks to covid there are a lot of
people going through a lot of problems
and we don't hear a thing about them and
all we keep hearing is what about the
trans kids and it and it's used to shut
down these real debates so somebody has
to come armed with actual data at some
point
and it's used to make a lot of money
it's multi-billion dollars oh yeah and
it keeps making more and more every year
it's about the money coming up Democrats
and a frenzy to stop Joe manchin from
spoiling Joe Biden's path hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else